un été sous le signe de l'inquiétude les
abandons d'animaux ont explosé ces
derniers mois entre le 1er mai et le 31
juillet plus de 12000 ont été recueillis
par la spa à 7% de plus en deux ans
conséquence les 62 refuge de
l'association sont aujourd'hui quasiment
à saturation notamment ici sur le site
d'orgeval jeu peut accueillir 80 chiens
aujourd'hui j'ai
78 chien présent on est en période de
vacances donc on sait qu'en cette
période si on n'a pas beaucoup
d'adoptants mais là ça va bientôt
devenir dramatique les chats c'est
pareil j'ai beaucoup de chats présents
sur le site et je vais plus pouvoir
accueillir
l'abandon de transfert ou d'arrivée de
fourrière ça va ça va pas être possible
les adoptions elles sont moins
nombreuses en ce moment à la situation
est donc alarmante et l'été 2000 21 bat
tous les records uniquement pour les
chats et les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie les recueils ont grimpé de 23%
par rapport à 2019 le confinement a
laissé des traces les gens n'ont pas
stériliser leurs animaux déjà d'une part
très certainement que les personnes
qu'on soit achetés en animalerie soit
adopter un animal pendant le confinement
est là comme on est des confiner les
personnes partent en vacances
malheureusement c'est le malheureux
constat que l'on fait l aspa milite pour
une adoption responsable en actes qui
doit être réfléchie et qui peut se faire
avec l'aide de professionnels comme le
rappelle la dernière campagne de
l'association very bad trip est les
premiers à souffrir dès abandons ce sont
bien sûr les admins